hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at a little bit
of an optimization of how we could
basically make our render A to D out of
urine bura a lot simpler in the in the
sense that we had a kind of one shed if
everything make sure you guys check out
that video if you haven't already
because it's a cool little optimization
and it's a different kind of way of
thinking I think that video is quite
good now today we're gonna be talking
about what we said we would last time
which was basically taking a little bit
of a look at performance and timing and
benchmarking and profiling there's a lot
of it a lot of these kind of buzzwords
floating around here what we're gonna do
today is I'm kind of probably gonna
introduce this like as an introduction
today because this is gonna end up being
like a 2 or 3 pot miniseries within I
guess this game engine series well we're
just basically going to talk about you
know how we can both change our card I
guess modify our code in a way that
allows us to record some metrics such as
CPU usage CPU time basically and then
also how to kind of I guess look at and
analyze that data in a meaningful way
because you know in this kind of topic
there's there's two sides the right
there's two sides of the coin there's
the actual collecting data right so you
need to figure out what data you want
what numbers are gonna be useful to you
you know for example we might want to
know how long one frame takes how long
the kind of updating of the camera takes
how long clearing the render attacks
even maybe you wanna if you want to kind
of drill down into it specific grande
recommends you want to kind of like like
lay this out and be like yeah when I hit
the mouse button when I render I am
going well everything that happens in my
game engine in my game I would like to
know how long everything takes so that
way if you know if everything's kind of
taking one millisecond and there's this
one function that every frame is taking
five milliseconds I know that
maybe I should optimize that specific
area of code if you're kind of flying
blind in a way where you just you just
don't know like what is slow what is
fast you kind of look at your frame and
your frame rates just like 20 or
something and just not performing well
it can be difficult to drill down and
actually figure out what's wrong so
that's kind of the the sense that okay
well I want to know how long every
function text for example right I want
to know this on update is sandbox 2d on
update function that we have here how
many milliseconds every frame am i
spending inside that function doing that
function right how much time is my
renderer spending actually rendering
these quads you know do I need to speed
that up and of course that's gonna be
important because when we do move on to
optimizing our end virtuti because it is
a very simple kind of one quad per draw
style 2d renderer at this point when we
do optimize it it's gonna be really nice
to see that massive performance benefit
that we do get and that's why that's why
I want to get all this always kind of
timing profiling stuff done now the
other side of that coin that the other
side of this profiling problem that I
think people don't realize as often is
once I have that data what what am I
gonna do with it okay cool it at three
milliseconds here right do I really want
like a list of numbers that just tells
me that okay this took five months that
consists of three milliseconds this to
0.5 this took point three okay cool how
does this work that's probably not a
very good way of doing it I want to
actually visualize this data somehow
apart from just maybe seeing it visually
to begin with I also want to maybe
record specific trends in the data or
whatever you know for example what
happens if 10 frames are fine but then
every 10th frame or something or every
50th frame there's a bit of a hitch why
does that why does that happen I want to
kind of draw attention to that weed that
out because that might be information
that's useful to me and then of course
yeah visualizing the data would be
incredible as well so all these things
are things that were gonna cover in this
little miniseries we're gonna basically
just I don't want to spend too long on
this and I and I am actually planning to
make us
to learn videos specifically about like
profiling and benchmarking in fact I do
have video on benchmarking in C++
definitely check that out because I'm
actually going to be using some of the
code from that video here today but
basically I don't wanna spend too long
on this so today we're just gonna like
see if we can get some numbers out and
then next week next episode we're gonna
see if we can visualize those numbers
somehow I do want to point out as well
that this is going to be completely
independent of any kind of tooling right
I don't want to tie this to Visual
Studio for example now this is another
little discussion
there are profiling tools available
every IDE probably has a profiler built
in a partner and aside from that there's
obviously standalone profilers which
will basically can look at your code and
be like okay well this is how long every
function takes that's something the
visual studio does offer and I might
cover that in a different video probably
part of the C++ series or something like
that just a standalone video it's good I
won't lie the profiling tools in Visual
Studio I'm not bad at all but it's
better to ultimately it's better to not
necessarily better but you know yeah
like for example I would still use
visual studios profiling tools even if I
had man but in a lot of cases it makes a
lot of sense to write your own profiling
tools the reason is that it's gonna be
something that is inside your code base
and because of that you know presumably
you kind of distance yourself if it's
not kind of part of the development
environment you choose to work in right
it's part of your actual code libraries
part of your actual engine that's really
useful because suddenly that doesn't
that means that I don't need to be using
Visual Studio I don't need to have
Visual Studio hooked into my code to see
how fast things take right that's not
good what if I'm deploying on Mac well
all I can use Xcode and that has some
like instrumentation tools great
what about Linux you know I'll have to
use a different profile now what about
Android what about iOS what about
consoles you know you start ending up
with all of this this kind of situation
here where it's like you know I have I'm
using a different tool for every
platform and not only that but I have
have like a debugger connector or I have
to have like this profiling tool
connected to my app to actually see how
fast everything is what if just randomly
on a special build will say of my code
when I'm running on some users machine
for example right there downloaded my
gambler my friend play my game it's
running really slowly on his computer I
understand why because he's got a great
graphics card or whatever right I want
to see what's going on well wouldn't it
be nice to just flip on a switch get all
that data out analyze it be able to look
at it and see what's wrong without
having to be like a cable first you're
gonna have to download Visual Studio and
am I gonna have to we don't want that
right that this might have been a
long-winded explanation but my point is
it's really nice to have your own tools
and by doing that you know we can easily
kind of take a look at every function in
our code it's called instrumentation
when we actually go through our code and
we add additional code basically that
will track all of these things this is
definitely something that you want to
shut off for distribution bills it's
usually just used for debug builds or
broglie's builds it usually has its own
flag as well because you don't want it
to be running all the time or being
compiled into your code all the time so
that anyway there's a lot of things we
can talk about I don't want to again I
don't want to make this huge malicious
dive in we're gonna take a time on class
from the benchmarking and say false
false code
sorry benchmarking in C++ video that I
have linked up there then I made a while
ago we're gonna take that time a class
we're gonna change that around a little
bit and then we're gonna see if we can
record some basic metrics from within
sandbox 2d to begin with and you know
what else I want to give a huge thank
you to all the patrons that made this
series possible petrichor full slash the
Cherno series will not be here without
you guys I've done some pretty exciting
things lately I've had an exclusive
video about talking about how I'm
getting Vulcan into hazel and also of
course there is a hazel development
branch it's becoming it what I want to
do with with patreon what I want to do
with that with those exclusive videos is
kind of treat them as like a weekly
devlog right not one that not not like
the one that went up on youtubers or
like fancy it's all like these cinnamon
cinematic like shots and everything
and it's like to tip it took me like a
week to edit I don't want anything like
that just a quick and dirty video pretty
much live just like a live stream almost
about me just kind of being like okay
well this is what I did with hazel this
week well this is what I did with you
know my channel this week or whatever
look a little dev vlog because me
working by myself is a full-time
youtuber it's a little bit difficult to
stay accountable to all these things
that I'm working on so I think that if I
was to make a weekly video of of course
myself every Monday morning or every
Friday because it's like the end of the
week to just kind of make a video but
I'm like this is what I did all week and
show off a bunch of things I think that
would probably be very healthy for me
and it'd be cool for you guys to see as
well so that's kind of the plan I guess
I should probably do the first of these
videos like tomorrow cuz tomorrow's
Friday we'll see anyway um so that's
what's going on and of course thank you
so much for helping to support my
channel let's get into this profiling
stuff okay so this is what we had at the
moment again you know this is week two
this last episode is not really worth
talking to much about it yeah I want to
see how long everything text that's kind
of the goal for today I'm just gonna
scroll up to the very top of this file
this is the sandbox to D del CBP file
we're gonna be like real quick and dirty
yeah because I just want to show you
guys how this works I'm gonna paste in a
basic timer clause this is basically the
same thing that was in the the
benchmarking supersoul video I changed a
little bit we're taking in a con strong
point as the name here and we're doing
some other loose stuff but basically
it's really simple right what we do is
it's kind of scope based it's ra íí-
which basically just means that when we
constructed it starts up and when we
destroy it it stops right and in fact
this is annoying me slightly I'm just
gonna move the destructor over here so
basically all it's doing again is it's
starting the timer when we actually
construct the object and when we destroy
the object if it however if it hasn't
already been stopped it will record the
endtime point and then calculate the
distance between the two to get our
duration in milliseconds which we should
probably also write okay cool
so you might have a few questions about
this again
is just an example piece of card one of
the questions might be what might be why
are we using comps child pointers this
is not C as C++ yes it is but I don't
want to store an entire like
heap-allocated string or anything like
that because this is meant to be a
static string and you know we can talk
about strings in a future episode but
basically if you have a static string
static meaning that is literally typed
in like this it's not like a variable
it's not mutable at all it's something
that's literally written in the code as
a static string then you do not want to
use STD string because by doing so you
know you're basically apart from the
potential heap allocation and all that
there's so much there's so much
unnecessary overhead because it really
you know what is a string it's just a
bunch of characters it's a memory
address that we have with a buffer that
has a bunch of characters that's all I
need it for because it's going to be a
static string okay cool so that's out of
the way
let's talk about how we can use this
well at the moment all it does is it
outputs this to the console now that's
great let's see it in action quickly I'm
just gonna grab this timer we probably
need to include burner as well if we go
over here to all on update that's a good
candidate for this I'll type in time and
time I will have to give it a name I'll
give it the name of this function so
sandbox 3d on update this is what I mean
by a static string right this is never
gonna be something that we like take in
from from a file or gets generated in
any way through our program code just a
static string and that should be it like
if I just run this program now
theoretically we should know how long
this on update function takes because
what are we doing we're printing it to
the console now we get a value that's
between 0 and 1 well I mean sometimes a
0 sometimes is one most the time is 0
the reason that this is happening of
course is because you know we're we're
treating this is milliseconds we've told
our timer we want milliseconds so it's
giving us to the closest millisecond
we'll change this to microseconds to
make this a little bit more clear and
then I'm probably just through order
you know duration equals so we had n
minus dot I'm actually gonna make this
exploit and - stop and then I'll
multiply it by point zero zero one just
to get that from microseconds in two
milliseconds so now that we have this we
can replace that with that and we should
get something a little bit more precise
here alright and here we go to three
decimal places we seem to be getting a
pretty accurate timing here of how long
our update cycle actually takes so
specifically the user based update cycle
meaning the actual client code on update
function okay brilliant so we've got
that that's fantastic now having that
data in the console is a little bit well
not very useful because we have to look
at the console also if we have numerous
ones of these for example we have
sandbox Treaty on update and which
probably actually look like the name or
something like that instead of just um
you know a function and instead of just
duration as a static string but anyway
if I want to see for example this is
code based remember right so if I want
to see for example you know camera
on/off date and instead of actually
putting it into the camera control
function we're gonna put it here if I
want to see something like this and I
probably don't even have to rename this
I can just you know will do camera
controller on update you know it's not
bad like I want to see all the data here
but I'm just kind of trying to
demonstrate to you guys why it's not
great this is clearly a mess right I'd
much rather see it like you know I'm
gooey and eventually maybe in some kind
of visual way so how do we do that well
I'm gonna kind of quickly add something
to this that's gonna actually make it so
that we can visualize this not really
visualizes but see this an IM GUI I'm
acting inside like an actual control I
make a little struct called profile
result this is gonna basically contain a
Const name and then we'll also have the
actual time so this kind of profile
result I'll just make a vector of these
so that we can have basically unlimited
amounts of these kind of profile results
we'll say and then what I want to do is
I want
actually kind of I gets pushed back into
that vector when I actually get a
profile result and maybe over here I'll
have some kind of section where I just
go through all of the profile results so
a result in purple results and then what
we'll do in some form or another will
just present this in time ability so
I'll just use I'm Joey text which is
like a formatted text option and then
maybe I can do something like the name
of the result and then eventually like
there's also in fact if we were to do
this we need to concatenate two strings
so it may be let's just make like a I'll
call this label little buffer here so
that we can use so we have to use a
function we don't have to use safe
functions again you could convert this
into it send a string and do everything
there but I'm trying to be a little bit
more mindful of performance I guess and
we can just do this all on the stack
really easily by just doing this so
label is our destination source
I guess we'll put the name of the the
name of the profile result and then into
labor wall so concatenate the so what is
this label have to be okay for formatted
labels so in other words we'll have the
name right which is already in there and
then we'll have two spaces and then
percentage point to F and then m/s for
milliseconds so this should give us the
time I guess I'll do point three for
more precision that will give us the
time in milliseconds so now we can do
label and then resolved all time okay so
we're just basically this is just the
same as printf we're formatting were
basically formatting our label here so
that it not only contains the name but
then followed by the name it following
the name it has our time two to three
decimal places okay cool so we've got
that pretty simple now we have to have
some way of actually I guess putting
this back into here now we could do some
crazy things here I mean I'll probably
have to modify the time because I'll
make it a little bit better I think I'll
make it a little bit more you
vessel what I'll do instead of this is
they'll actually pass in a lambda which
will return a profile result and then
this profile result so I can just
probably Sasori um
this profile result I'll then be able to
do something like profile results I'll
push back and then profile the result
okay so but I'll basically just have
something like something like this and
we'll take us by reference of course so
we have profile results push back
profile result so that'll actually get
it in there and then obviously as soon
as I ran to them I want to clear them so
we'll just be clear here
okay sounds good to me obviously we need
to extend the API to include this and
then yeah should be it should be good so
what I'll do is I'll add now I could I'm
taking an STD function here that will
probably cause my cause that heap
allocation it's slightly better in this
case and it's gonna be throw away time
anyway so it's it's quite nice and
display in this case to actually use
this lambda without having to construct
an STD function object and because a
lambda will actually generate a type
that is basically unique to this lambda
there's no way for us to capture that
really so we have to use something like
templates or order to actually handle it
so what I'll do is I'll just use our
template here so this will be like our
function I'll call it funk I'm just
taking it in as a double reference here
and then I'm going to well we'll copy it
into this class we'll just have em funk
like that and I'll just be FN here which
is like the this is essentially going to
be the type of lambda the DeBeers right
and it can be any wonder that's why
we're making this a template and then
what we'll do is we'll set up and font
what will set the vary the member
variable here I'll put a direct bound a
name and then instead of us doing this
all I'm gonna do is call back that pull
back right it's just gonna be lambda
that we're calling and we're gonna call
it with name so
and name and then duration okay so
that's it really so what this will do is
when the timer stops we're gonna call
this callback function which is our
lambda right and that's gonna well we're
giving it we're constructing a profile
result with name and duration and then
what that's gonna do is just go into M
profile results and push back that
profile result so now we now we should
have that list there and that's it and
realistically like you'd need to copy
this everywhere that's gonna get
annoying so I'm just gonna make a macro
define you know profile scope I guess
this is a scope profile will do timer
timer will probably make it unique with
the line number just in case you want to
do two and two in a row whatever cuz
otherwise you know that won't work for
example because they're called the same
thing whereas by using line working
cabanne working catenae ting the line
number which is just gonna give us like
the line number so you'll give us the
unique name of the whole point of this
thing and then we need to take in the
name which I guess yeah we just taking
the name and then we'll construct this
lambda which just basically put us back
our profile result that's it I think
right cool
okay so now we can just use profile
scarp with the name which is this pretty
cool so profile scarf sandbox 2d on
update and then purple scope camera
controller on update we might as well
change this around a little bit and make
it so that we'll just add stuff
basically so we have like this bottom
our Renda I'll just say renderer
renderer prep just like the preparation
for rendering I guess and then if we
wanted to
you know also do the actual arounder at
raw I guess right which kind of doesn't
begin scene and all about draw quads and
we put these into scope so the time it
should stop automatically everything
looks pretty good and I don't know if
this will work let's just see if I can
get this to our first try
well we got some errands
so that's great so yeah I did I did see
a suspicious amount of Kelly brackets
here also rather not Kelly brackets but
parentheses so yeah I guess we don't
know we don't need that extra one at the
end yeah let's hit f5 more errors okay
could not reduce template so this is
probably because we used order here and
it just it just can't reduce it so
whenever you get like T it's basically
just a continuous order error message so
this is a tough call result let's tell
it that f5 once again okay and we're
running pretty cool so if we where's our
window here it is if we look at this
window check this out so we have all
four of our timings here and they look
pretty good if we just click somewhere
on the title bar to freeze this you can
see how long everything takes so on
update is point zero to nine
milliseconds very fast then we have
point zero one three point zero nine
eight and then the actual I guess the
whole function so the drawing takes
about you know 0.1 millisecond which is
pretty quick and then sandbox 2d on
update text which is the entire function
all together takes 0.14 five
milliseconds which is very fast
okay cool sir one more thing I want to
do I'm regretting my decision here to
have it in that order I'm basically just
gonna flip this and then this will be a
string copy and then it's ranked at this
is basically just gonna make it so that
our time is first followed by the name
that way it will just be nicely aligned
unlike that mess that we saw before
okay that is better and there's some we
should probably get rid of this di am
GUI demo window in fact that's annoying
me so much is that inside I'm doing
layer or somewhere probably is yeah sure
demo window and I'm doing around that we
don't need that online do you render out
oh I think let's get rid of that entire
function because that I'm Google a
shouldn't be doing any I'm goo rendering
most likely you know even core stuff
should probably be coming from the
render or some way okay that's better
there we go so that's that's that right
we can see oh look I made a big I made a
full spoon and
took a bit more time it's still very
faster anyway this now shows us
everything that we want to know about
our profiles it's pretty cool you can
stick this anywhere right obviously this
is not like the most ideal thing in the
world for example if you have something
that isn't that frame like on event it'd
be pretty much impossible to track that
and then also you know this isn't like
saving out everything it's really kind
of hard to inspect it's a good rough way
to just be like okay cool you know my
sandbox drawing stuff is taking point to
one five milliseconds I'm cool that's
great and obviously if you add this
profile if you were to expand this and
add the profile scope macros all around
your code like in every function for
example so we added it into like render
HP begin same then drop quad and saner
everywhere then we would actually see
everything but having a long list of
everything over here is not ideal either
so that's why that's why the kind of
visualization of data comes in and
ultimately what we'll talk about in the
next episode if you guys you enjoyed
this video you can do it please hit that
like button as always you can help
support the series but go to
patreon.com/scishow now as i mentioned
earlier in this video next time we're
going to talk about what we can do with
this dot and now that we're actually
collecting milliseconds and we've got
this kind of timing code that's actually
collecting data what are we going to do
with it how we're gonna visualize it
we're gonna talk about that in the next
video I will see you guys later
good bye
[Music]